hey youtubers is Charlie so they just
revealed Kid Flash on the flash season 3
so let's break this down Wally West will
be Kid Flash on the flash season 3 now
this is the flash point season so they
did not clarify as to how he got his
powers if it was a result of what they
did last year with the attempt to reboot
Barry's powers which is a very
flashpoint type of moment in itself
anyway worth this as a result of Barry
changing the timeline by saving his
mother in the past but they did say like
the way they're making it sound is as if
we will see Kid Flash in episode 1 so
whatever's happened will either happen
during episode 1 or it will have
happened when Barry comes back so either
we'll see him discover his powers for
the first time in episode 1 or when
Barry comes back to the future and
notices all the changes he will notice
that there is one more flash than there
used to be so the real reason that
they're dropping this costume now and
not at Comic Con is because they were
filming outside and people were gonna
see it so they wanted to get ahead of
the leak like they were gonna be filming
with him in this costume in like a
darkened alley so on the off chance that
someone was gonna take pictures of it
leaked it to the Internet they're like
okay we'll just go ahead and release
these officially like nice big HD
awesome looking images so if you're
wondering why it's yellow it's because
the Kid Flash costume in the comics used
to be yellow now a lot of you have
wondered if this is just like a modified
version of the reverse flash costume
that's totally possible but a lot of
what's going on just depends on how the
timeline is different so it's a little
too early to speculate as to why they
created this costume is that how Wally
became Kid Flash why they call him Kid
Flash instead of just calling him the
flash so I'm assuming that Barry has
powers when we go back but let's talk
about the comic book version of the
costume so in the comics the original
Wally West is like a really little kid
he's way younger than this version of
Wally West Barry is way older so way way
back in the comics in flash number 110
Wally West debuts he is the nephew of
Barry Allen okay so iris West is married
to Barry Allen at the time iris West has
a sister named Mary West who has a son
named Wally West
she has an abusive husband who's really
bad to their son Wally so in order to
help him out she sends him to live with
Barry
for a little while who's working in the
crime lab one day Wally goes to visit
Barry at work has the same accident with
chemicals and lightning that Barry had
that gave him flash powers so Wally
becomes another version of the flash he
wears a costume that looks exactly like
Barry's but then an issue number 135
this is really crazy story of how wal I
got the yellow costume so he's running
from school and gets a telepathic
message from a woman from another
dimension who says that her race built
three super weapons so the flash travels
back to Central City to get help from
Barry but he becomes charged with energy
from one of the super weapons and it
changes his costume yellow switch is
like a creative narrative device to give
Kid Flash a different looking costume so
you don't have two versions of the flash
running around looking exactly the same
it's just you know so he gets like a
cool new looking costume so that's the
original story of how Wally West's
costume got turned yellow and how you
know I got that special headpiece it was
just so that he would look different
from Barry Allen when they were running
around fighting together so for the most
part Kid Flash is known for being part
of Teen Titans like he leaves the flash
title and goes into the Teen Titans
comic but that came after he met Robin
for the first time in the Brave and the
bold number 54 so they have an adventure
together and then later they had the
idea to form their own team so you get
the idea of Robins becoming Nightwing
Wally West has become Kid Flash they're
all like hey we should have our own team
and so that's how Wally West got the
yellow costume enjoying Teen Titans so
this all happened way back in the 60s so
I'll be interested to see if there are
any Easter eggs from those original
issues but here's the fun deep cut for
the first appearance of Wally West in
the comics so like I said he debuted at
issue number 110 the villain of that
issue was whether wizard if you remember
the first episode of the flash season 1
the original version of whether wizard
was the villain of that now later his
brother mark Mardon took the mantle and
became like a more fully realized
version of the character so we might see
him come back for a kid flash episode
but just look out for Easter eggs from
the first appearance of Kid Flash in the
comics but I know a lot of you are
asking ok so like this version of Wally
West is african-american like the new 52
version of Wally West so there will
probably be some Easter eggs for that
too but this story
the way he got his powers was really
cynical like I don't know they'll
probably go with a happier version of
the origin story so I'm expecting a
combination of new 52 Wally West origin
story with the original version of Wally
West if you've been reading the rebirth
comics than you know that because the
old version of Wally West came back
there are two versions of Wally West in
the comics right now the younger version
the african-american Wally West from new
52 he will stay inside the main flash
title the old version of Wally West that
came back from the Speed Force is part
of Teen Titans they changed his costume
to look red now the way they're
explaining that too I know there's two
Wally West so it's like this is getting
confusing the way they're saying it is
is that they're cousins that have just
never met so if you're not a big comic
book reader don't worry about that the
TV show will be we don'twe easier to
follow than what's going on in the
comics but I will be talking about flash
rebirth stuff in the comics there'll be
a new issue coming up real soon so let
me know in the comments what do you guys
think about the idea of Kid Flash on the
flash season 3 how do you think the
dynamic is gonna be with Barry because
it sounds like Barry will be like a
mentor to him Wally's kind of like his
little brother but he's not that much
younger so it's not like the comics
where it's like this really old person
with this really really young little kid
but because they said that he's debuting
in the first episode I would expect to
see some Wally West Flash stuff
happening in the season 3 trailer that
they drop a Comic Con in a couple weeks
that's actually happening in less than
two weeks so I will be doing a new video
for that and there's actually there's a
new round of the giveaway that starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so on that's a winner the next
time I post a DC video there's all kinds
of comic-con flash stuff that we have to
talk about but in related comic-book
news I was actually planning on making a
Hulk behind the scenes video for Thor
Ragnarok so there'll be like a new
teaser video for that posting later
tonight and a lot of you guys were
asking me this morning you know are you
gonna do a video for this you know of
course I'm always gonna do a video for
big stuff like this but if you want to
find out like if I'm actually making a
video for it or in the process of making
one usually I announce that stuff on
Twitter like holy Wally West Kid
Flash working on a video right now
usually that's what I use Twitter
Facebook Instagram for so the links for
that are like all right here so like you
can follow me there to find out what I
were
on next so like I'll be talking about
the whole video that I'm working on
while I'm working on it but what you
guys wait for me to post that you can
click here for my spider-man homecoming
behind the scenes video and you can
click here to learn more about what's
going on during the flash season 3 thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight